je m'appelle Raphaël et j'ai 16 ans
je m'appelle Alexandre et j'ai 14 ans
je m'appelle Samir et j'ai 15 ans
je m'appelle resa et j'ai 16 ans moi et
mes copains pensons que les visites les
vigiles ou les flics abusent souvent de
l'autorité et ça c'est pas juste il nous
arrive que lorsqu'on vient au Hal ou
dans des autres grandes surfaces
on va dans les rayons on regarde par
exemple des cassettes des télés on
regarde quoi ce qui nous intéresse des
disques de visuel tout ça et on dit
souvent interpellé par des vigiles où on
est souvent suivi du regard et assez
méchamment on y traite comme des chiens
galeux quand on nous regarde comme ça on
suit les yeux et ça c'est je trouve ça
un peu c'est humiliant des fois il sait
pas juste
on se déplace au Halles on a un but si
on vient pour acheter on vient pour
regarder le prix pour revenir quoi on
vient jamais pour pour galérer quoi pour
pour rester pour traîner pour voir ce
qui se passe et venez tu penses que
c'est parce que vous êtes en groupe
quand vous êtes un peu suspects
c'est-à-dire ils doivent penser les
vigiles doivent penser qu'on est mieux
organisé qu'on cache mieux notre jeu je
sais pas mais pourtant c'est pas ça quoi
moi et Samir l'autre fois on était avec
son cousin et son frère puis on était
venu acheter des cassettes
à la FNAC et puis en sortant du magasin
pourtant il y a des grilles de sécurité
qui font un bruit si par exemple on
passe avec les choses qu'on a pas acheté
et là on est passé sur un passé on a
commencé à sortir du magasin puis trois
vigilis sont venus ils nous ont dit
veuillez nous suivre pour vérification
de vos achats puis ils ont ils nous ont
amenés dans une pièce plus loin quoi
j'ai commencé un peu à nous fouiller
quoi comme ça
après ils ont vérifié le prix le ticket
de caisse et puis c'était bon quoi
penser qu'on vous assimile à des jeunes
qui se droguent ou ça on peut pas se
mettre à la place des visites des
vigiles ils peuvent penser ce qu'ils
veulent
vous avez l'impression que les policiers
et les vigiles ont une attitude
gratuitement agressive pas tous il faut
pas généraliser il y en a quelques-uns
bien sûr qui sont tout à fait normal
mais il y en a oui on se demande si
c'est vraiment si c'est du du racisme
vestimentaire parce que on habillé d'une
d'une façon du racisme tout court si on
se demande parce que on est je me suis
pas sur un homme de un garçon de couleur
et dès qu'il nous voit il ne regarde
méchamment qu'on avait qu'une doudoune
aussi il demande si on a volé quelque
chose sur les a pas mis dans les manches
on les amis dans les rêves ils sont
complètement tarés ils choisissent leur
leur victime on sort tout ça dès qu'il
voit il surveille une personne qui
arrive là-bas tiens on va prendre
celui-là moi j'ai parlé avec les rigides
et je leur ai expliqué mais pourquoi
vous faites que enfin apparemment il
faisait il faisait que ça aux jeunes
alors on dit
oh vous inquiétez pas de toute façon on
fait ça à tout le monde et moi j'y crois
pas je pense pas je pense qu'ils font ça
en priorité aux jeunes
j'ai aucune raison de voler moi mes
parents mechètent tout ce que je veux je
m'entendais avec mes parents mais
non moi j'ai aucune raison de voler mais
ça m'énerve qu'on comme soutient d'avoir
voulu quelque chose
je sais pas je me sens ridicule
tout à fait comme ça quoi on se sent
gêné
les gens par exemple quand on nous
emmène dans un bureau il nous regarde
comme ça on a vraiment l'impression que
quand on a folie quelque chose ou qu'on
a fait quelque chose qu'il fallait pas
faire
c'est pas agréable
je suis pas d'accord pour que les
vigiles nous fous mais des fois on peut
les comprendre
parce que il y a un certain stress une
nervosité ils doivent trouver quelqu'un
pour fouiller ils ont une victime entre
guillemets
trouve ça c'est bavette quoi vous avez
l'air louche ah non pas du tout non pas
du tout par rapport à d'autres
[Musique]